foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
check out Adam Levine rocking out on
stage as he makes his first public
appearance since finding himself at the
center of a cheating scandal Adam and I
were seeing each other for about a year
Adam performs with his band for
Shaquille O'Neal's the event fundraiser
in Las Vegas
[Music]
and Shaq even joins him for his hit song
This Love
[Music]
foreign
this comes after an Instagram model
alleges that she had an affair with the
Maroon 5 front man who was currently
expecting his third child with wife
Behati Prinsloo if we're good the kids
are good we're just a good team last mom
Sumner stroe released a series of viral
tick tocks which showed alleged
flirtatious DMS between her and Adam I'd
say a lot of things you know and some
some things I stand by and some things I
you know put my foot in my mouth a
little bit uh yeah essentially
I was having an affair with a man who's
married to Victoria's Secret model at
the time you know I was
young I was naive and
I mean quite frankly I feel exploited I
wasn't in the scene like I am now
um so I was definitely very easily
manipulated following the hearsay Adam
responded to Sumner's claims and a
statement on his Instagram story posting
in part quote I used poor judgment in
speaking with anyone other than my wife
in any kind of flirtatious manner I did
not have an affair nevertheless I
crossed the line during a regrettable
period in my life since then numerous
women have come forward with their own
claims of receiving flirty messages from
the singer and when it comes to how the
drama is affecting Adam's relationship
with bahati a source tells ET that while
Adam admits he crossed the line he also
maintains he never physically cheated
saying quote he's selling Behati and his
friends that although someone claimed
there was a physical relationship it
never happened and although Adam loves
attention from women he knows he crossed
the boundary and is telling his wife it
will never happen again the real you no
matter what like it or not the real you
is coming out no matter how close you
play your cards uh you better just
embrace it and now he's trying to make
things right with bahati who a source
sells ET is upset about how everything
was handled in the public aspect of it
but it's trying to move past the
situation as their children are their
top priority body opened up to ET last
year about how she and Adam prioritize
their marriage I think at the core of it
we're truly just we're truly best
friends you know and we we really get
each other on a on a deeper level so
when there's a lot going on and and he's
on tour and I'm busy and the kids and
stuff we always
we have so much fun together that we
always want to be together so we make
that happen you know what I mean yeah
um so it comes really easily I mean it's
tough with with life happening and
things work and you know
everything going on to always find that
time but I I think we've
we've set a pretty high standard for us
as a couple individual the two of us
aside from the kids and family and all
of that to really just make sure we're
good
foreign